what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things youtube channel today i am going
to be reacting to brittany lee i fell
off my celebi celibacy journey so you
don't have to before i start don't
forget to subscribe to the channel and
bring that notification bell that way
you're going to be notified of my daily
videos while you're at it if you have
watched three or more of my videos and
you have not subscribed me and you we
got beef
beef
okay
i
this studio is tough to afford i do this
for you guys
just hit it please please okay
let's go
my mind
also follow my instagram
it's just dot pearly things
just dot pearly things okay
everything that i did not want to do i
did it after 11 years i literally felt
like a failure still trying to figure
out how they helped to get back onto the
celibacy thing because i've eaten the
forbidden fruit it tasted great and i
don't know if i want to be celebrating i
don't know if i can be celebrate again
hey guys welcome back to my channel hope
you guys are doing well as you can see
by the title yes yes yes this is not
clickbait okay this is real live today
we are talking about celibacy my
celebrity story where i'm at now where
i've been and where i'm finna go
now so this is gonna be really
interesting
watching this through a red pill lens oh
i'm excited i'm not a christian you are
more than welcome to watch the video
even if it doesn't apply to you or even
if you feel like it doesn't apply to you
fire asks one special thing do not come
and throw your beliefs over what i
believe as a born again christian these
are my thoughts these are my beliefs and
it's what the bible says okay so you are
more than welcome i do not discriminate
channel i know a lot of christians and i
know i have a lot of followers that are
not christians i am catering to the
christians today and i will be doing so
in a few other videos this year too
where i speak directly to my christians
and the reason why i say this is not to
isolate people to make people feel not
included but there's some things that
only christians understand such as the
topic of celibacy
okay i would consider myself christian
so this is this will be interesting
before i start i want to say this video
is not at all about condemnation
it's not about shame it's not about
making
shame
guilty but it is about truth and at the
end of the day you are always free to
make your own life choices that is
between you and your creator however
this
is my story so many of you know me
through my celibacy video it's always
really interesting to like hear how
people started following me or were
privy to me and a lot of you followed me
through my celibacy journey where i was
sharing over five years ago on this
channel about celibacy and my story so i
put out a video in
2016 where nobody really was talking
about celebrity nobody was really
talking about anything substantial to be
honest which is why the video stuck out
i was very raw very real very honest
probably too honest which actually
invited a lot of judgment and criticism
i've never ever hidden away from
controversy and talking about things
that are real life and a lot of things
that there's a lot of things that we
just need to talk about and stop like
stop making it taboo that's why i like
coming on here and just airing out my
business which is what it actually seems
like but i'm not honestly god as my
witness i would not be doing this
without god's grace and his leading and
his mercy and his power yeah and his
love i know that these videos help oh my
gosh get to it lady
people even if it's something that i
don't necessarily want to share or it's
something that i have shame about i know
that it has to help somebody that's the
reason why i've been asked by the most
high to make these kind of videos i made
that video in 2016
and then i went on to talk about my
eight years of celibacy and how i was
finding oh my gosh
she didn't have sex for eight years
the following year in 2017 i put out
another video and i was basically asking
the question
am i still celibate because people were
still asking me at the time and the
answer was yes in that video i said
these words pray for me and the
following year in 2018 is when
i
fell now 2008 i need to know her age
this would help me britney
lee age so
so famous birthdays
so she's 30 i want to say
okay and
so five so she would have been 25 i'm
just cute like what ages would she
celebrate details is irrelevant but what
i will say is that i was getting way too
close to the edge i was playing with
fire i was almost saying how close can i
get without actually doing it and i
got burned it happened like that and i
was
mortified i felt angry at the person
that i was dating at the time but he
quickly let me know that he didn't force
me it was a choice that i made and he
was correct so the months to come after
that incident i was so disillusioned and
confused and i really did not know who i
was as a christian and i realized the
day i got saved in 2007 was the day i
literally stopped having sex
literally the day
i stopped having sex so my salvation and
my celibacy became one in the same which
really shook me to my core i realized
that i had attached my ability to be
celibate to my salvation so i'm thinking
to myself am i even saved am i really
saved and i know that may sound crazy to
you guys but at the time i was just so
gosh i really wish i had the ages here
so
she said
so at 25 she was celibate
and then she broke it around like 27 i
think before 25
she didn't have sex for eight years so
since
25 20 so since she was 17
wow that's irrational this is very not
red pill
maybe if it's the ages i'm thinking the
very thing that i did not want to do i
did it after 11 years i
did it i literally felt like a failure
and i did not speak about celibacy again
until now because i was not going to be
a hypocrite i only talk about stuff that
is real right and what's real for me and
what's going on with me at the moment at
the time and what i can actually do to
encourage or add value to you guys but i
literally had nothing to encourage you
guys with i had literally nothing
that i could say listen i've always
believed in celibacy since i got saved
and just because i was okay let me talk
about
this is this is the conversation you
have to have
with young girls because this is what
you don't understand i relate to her so
much in the fact that i really wanted to
wait till i was married to have sex like
i
i think i was
20 when i lost my virginity and i
i really really wanted to wait
but the problem is
you're basically telling the next guy
that you have to pay a higher price you
have to marry me
when the last guy got it for free
now
i'm not saying you can't find that there
are girls that do they find guys with
the same values but it's
it's gonna be a hell of a lot more
difficult
the more people that you've slept with
a hell of a lot more difficult
one guy
you know but then once you start
like the more and more and more like
like if a girl's had sex with 50 guys
and you're gonna tell the next guy he
has to wait
what what guy's gonna be a taker not
many i promise you not many now
now i don't know many girls that have
had sex with that many guys that want to
do that anyway but that's the problem
they don't talk about in the church they
just say oh no matter what you've done
god will forgive you and you can just be
celibate and you'll find a husband that
may not be the case ladies
be careful be careful what you do
because that your actions
are directly going to dictate what kind
type what type of husband you get
okay don't celebrate anymore did not
mean that i wouldn't champion it or i
don't still think it's the best option
however my conscience wouldn't allow me
to make a video about celibacy when i
literally was not even celebrate so i
had no i really do think it's the best
option when you're a virgin but the
problem is
if you're not a virgin it's a hard sell
and the older you get ladies the older
you get the harder of a cell it's gonna
be like she's 30.
what guy is going to wait till he's
married with the 30 year old
respectfully
respect let me know if you find one but
she hasn't yet
and especially a guy if you want him to
be like attractive make a lot of money
like if you want him to have the
qualities that a lot of women want you
think
he's going to wait for your not virgin
ass good luck
let me know to come on here and
encourage you guys with because i was
still trying to figure it out i was
trying to refine myself in god in my
sexuality in my celibacy i was still
trying to find myself because you guys
have to understand being celebrated for
11 years in the most crucial parts of my
life most of my teenage years and most
of my 20s i am celebrate there's nothing
happening there's no action so 11 11
years so
27 28
oh my gosh that's impressive that's very
impressive to be honest two years was a
very very very long time for me and then
before you know it i'm back in the
lion's den thinking to myself whether
it's even possible to get back onto the
celibacy again
and this is the problem this is why the
church keeps women single
oh my goodness like that shouldn't
happen oh my gosh that shouldn't happen
that should not happen so fast forward a
year i'm still very much confused
powerless still trying to figure out how
the hell to get back onto the celibacy
thing oh it's interesting though she
broke her celibacy around the epiphany
phase
which if you don't watch red pill you'd
have to
it's tough to explain but basically like
at around 27
or 28 27 28 to
like 35 ish is a woman's epiphany phase
which
basically means
that women um
are just in more of a rush to like find
somebody
and
they start to realize they can't compete
with their past selves so like mentally
it's not even like a physical thing all
the time but the options that you had at
27
or 28 are very different than the
options you had at 18.
it's not it's not a fun truth i don't
enjoy it but it's just you know how it
is because i've eaten the food and fruit
it tasted great and i don't know if i
want to be celebrating i don't know if i
can be celebrate again so i'm all out
living my best life and just not been
thinking about it and then i meet my ex
so we were both christians but i was a
very weak one at the time a very
defeated one at the time bro if you've
been waiting 11 years oh my god
i've gone like two three years without
having sex
i can't even 11. and he was well a man i
actually remember him saying to me i
don't want to kiss you until we're
married and i was thinking to myself oh
finally a christian guy that actually is
trying to do something right and live
according to the bible but at the same
time me i was indifferent i was thinking
kissing
me who cares like i was thinking to
myself i'm not going to set any
boundaries if that's what you're saying
okay prove yourself i'm not going to set
any boundaries and if it happens it
happens because kissing like for me at a
time that was like work i was just like
if it happens it happens and it did
happen guys have you ever ever ever been
so hungry and you're out and about and
the moment you come home you just want
to devour
everything that is literally what
happened with us literally making out
for hours
do you guys ever wonder when like in the
movies they like start ripping each
other's clothes off like
like a beast like i've never experienced
that before but i'm like why is it
always so dramatic anyway i say that to
say that no kissing until marriage
lasted for a week two weeks three weeks
i don't know i remember but it didn't
last long when it happened it was like
it's like popcorn mate so a while after
that we became official and we decided
well i decided we decided to consecrate
our relationship if you know what i mean
i'm not gonna lie to you guys i did not
feel bad at all i did not feel bad at
the time at all because i was like
wow
is this what sex feels like when you're
in love with someone because before i
became celibate at 16 i was just having
casual x but i was like this is so cool
when you're in love the ex
bangs i honestly
understand why it is so hard to stop
when you have popped especially when
you're in a relationship god damn lord
purify my mind but yeah when you're in
love like
or when you think you're in love the sex
is just
and it's like no wonder i wanted to
marry him so quickly like i was like i
could do this forever
anyway so a soul tie was formed very
very quickly and after a while okay this
is my opinion on soul ties
this is so this is so awkward to talk
about and i really don't like talk about
this stuff but
i
i think soul ties are only formed if the
girl like
for the girl anyway if she
if
you know don't make me say it don't make
me say it
um
yeah you guys get it i don't like it um
so
i don't know i will say like be careful
especially girls like be careful who you
sleep with because
it's very i hate breakups i get very
attached like easily to be honest and so
when i'm in love like i'm really in love
and i'll stay through like a lot even if
it's not a good relationship
because you're just like in love and you
care about that person so much
so my advice is to be very wise before
you sleep with somebody because you have
no idea
like like chemicals are released in our
brain when we have sex so you know be
careful with that stuff
and it's tough also because i really do
believe that the best way
for women
is like to wait till you're married to
have sex like ideally that's what i
think i would like to do
but you know that's like a tough sell
when
like you're not a virgin anymore and
that's what the church doesn't talk
about
they say like there's forgiveness for
everything but
it's gonna be a tough sell start to feel
bad we would repent set boundaries break
the boundaries repent set boundaries
break the boundaries repent repeat
repeat repeat that went on for
two
years and it was the most unstabling
period in my life with my relationship
with god i did everything to try
and stop
i will say i was before i got into my
last relationship i was doing bible
studies like once a week
and it is very hard to oh gosh
maintaining a relationship with
god and
like being involved in your church and a
relationship in real life is tough
especially if the guy you're dating
isn't a christian and isn't going to do
that stuff with you like
that's tough that's very tough so i
don't know but be careful who you date
but the other problem is there aren't as
many men in the church so i don't know
if it's the best advice to say only date
someone that's in the church because you
know then my dad my mom wouldn't have
met my dad my dad's a great husband
so i don't know there's pros and cons of
everything in life if i'm being honest
and i was
trying to understand at a time why i
couldn't stop and it was because deep
down i felt if we took away this aspect
of our relationship i wouldn't be
attracted to him there wouldn't be much
left for us to do
and it sounds really sad but maybe
that's the case for a lot of you guys
relationship the reason why you can't
stop is because you haven't built a
foundation of friendship you haven't
built a foundation of genuine but here's
the problem you're talking about
you and you're not thinking about the
guy
and men that's how they fall in love
they fall in love through sex
i mean it's not it's not a fun reality
but you you talk i've talked to a lot of
guys and there are many that will say
the relationship doesn't start until we
have sex
and
there are christian guys that'll you
know wait and like you know
look at things differently but they're
there's not a ton
there's not a ton love all you have is
good sex and that's it but how sad is
that like deep down i knew he wasn't my
husband so i couldn't honor him and he
couldn't honor me either so the
inconsistency of falling getting my car
falling really affected my relationship
with god it wasn't that god of change
but i felt shame to even pray to him i
would always repent repenting is
actually changing direction it isn't
getting up and doing the same thing over
again so i found it very difficult to
pray to god when i know that next week
we're gonna get it on i'm repenting
because i i feel bad like i kind of went
through this to be honest because in my
last
before my last relationship i really
wanted to wait till i was married to
have sex like that was something i
really wanted to do
but you know you fall in love things
change and
yeah like i i had a hard time praying
too because you're just like
how am i gonna pray
when i'm doing this like that's that's
re i relate actually i really haven't
liked a lot of her dating advice in the
past like i did a video just saying i
was not a fan
but a lot of the stuff she's talking
about right here is true i i'm sorry
that i feel bad but i'm gonna go and do
it on tuesday too guys do you want me to
be real or no so every time it happened
i felt convicted there wasn't a time
that i didn't feel convicted there was a
time when i was just like i can't stop
so i'm just gonna do it because all this
feeling bad is for the birds it's crap
it feels horrible so i'm just like i'm
not even gonna repent i'm not i'm just
gonna do it just keep on doing it until
god you helped me i was always convicted
and for those of you are wondering what
is conviction and in my definition or in
my experience the conviction of god is
when the truth of god which is him
speaking towards the truth hits what
we're actually doing which is wrong and
when it hits what's wrong the light that
comes in is what often makes us feel
ashamed and run away when adam and eve
ate the fruit that god told them not to
eat it was like suddenly a light bulb
came on and they knew they were naked
and they would they do okay this this
right here is why i have a rule with the
rest of my life that i'm trying
i think i followed it
think about it yeah yeah i followed it i
had to think about it but
be careful what doors you open
i stop drinking right
but i'm always gonna have that like
voice inside of me that wants to drink
honestly like
drinking's fun getting drunk out of your
mind getting effed up it's fun it has
consequences that i don't think are
worth it and that's why i stopped
but you have to understand like
if i never drank i would never know what
it's like that's why i've never done a
harder drug past like i think i smoked
in college but i didn't like it it was
not fun
so it was like you know i could count
the amount of times i did it but
be careful what doors you open it's the
same thing with having sex
once you open that door it's very hard
to close it
it's the same thing with you know
cheating on someone i've never cheated
right
but
if you do choose to cheat on your
significant other that's a habit you're
building that's the that's the
especially the younger we are the
choices we make now affect who we're
going to be in 10 20 years so it is so
it's so so so important
to just really watch what doors you open
be careful man they hid themselves
that's what happens like we hide
ourselves from god because god is light
and in him is no darkness so when we
feel like we've fallen short we hide
ourselves from him but towards the end
of my last relationship i started to
have a lot more dreams of me basically
perishing i didn't go to hell we was in
a plane together and the plane started
expiring down down down down and it's
like i can't remember exactly what i
said but i said something like we are
going to hell because of what we've been
doing this is what's in the dream it's
not me consciously it's what i said in
the dream so it's like my spirit knew so
i was getting all these dreams and these
kind of warnings and i would always tell
my partner like we need to start i've
got this dream and he was very
nonchalant about it and one thing i can
say is that he did not lead me in purity
and that's not to say i didn't have any
responsibility but as a man as a leader
as someone that i thought was going to
be my husband it's his job to lead in
purity
i disagree
i disagree
sorry
i as women we control the sex
men are always going to want to f you
sorry
they are i don't care if he's the most
god-fearing man on the planet men want
to have sex
it's our job to pick who we have sex
with and if we have sex
because if we want to can't become
husband and wife he'll be the leader of
the house which is spiritually
emotionally financially mentally he's a
leader so i was practically carrying the
whole load and the relationship on my
back a man is supposed to lead if you're
a believer a man is supposed to lead you
in purity it's not up to you sis to be
telling him we shouldn't do this we
can't do this it's literally your job
i'm sorry no stop why do women always
put the blame on the men stop
you chose to have sex with him
you made your bed lying it girl
like please it's your own fault
okay i was i was celibate before i met
my boyfriend that was my own damn fault
like
stop stop blaming men for everything he
should be the one saying listen babe i
love you so much but we have to honor
god that's a real man if your man does
not say that he's not the one god has
for you another thing that i want to
touch on this was my first real
relationship that i ever tried to be
celibate in and i think the moment i got
into relationship i was saying to myself
all these people that said they waited
until their wedding night to have sex i
was like y'all are lying lying because
ain't no way you can be a two three year
relationship without wanting to bone but
to be honest i don't know if these
couples are lying on or whatever but
maybe that was my flesh speaking but one
thing i do know is you can't do celibacy
in your flesh you can't do it with your
own i think if you're gonna be celibate
you shouldn't be in a two-three-year
relationship like you should get married
fairly quickly
i would you know guess if that's the
outcome you want to have to be honest i
would get married in six months if it
felt right to be honest if like that
person had everything i wanted and we
didn't and we had like a good
relationship i would i would do it in
six months i'm kind of i'm kind of a
ballsy person though like i make a lot
of bold moves a lot of bold moves power
you can't do it with your own mind i did
that for 11 years and it was tragic
abstinence is a spiritual principle to
spiritual command so if it's spiritual
it takes god to keep you need god's help
i need god's help but i will say the one
thing that you're doing as a girl and
rolo tomasi like these are his ideas
basically as a female you get access to
sex so much quicker than men like men
don't get that till later in life so
if you basically hook up with a bunch of
guys and then say oh i'm celibate you're
like trying to
increase your value basically and say oh
i'm more valuable
i don't want to say that i am but sort
of
and you're basically saying oh you new
guy who might actually want to marry me
you have to pay a higher price than all
the other guys who got it for free
now
i'm not saying like you shouldn't try to
wait till you're married like a lot of
people do that and they you know mess up
and then do it the second time right but
what i'm saying is you're gonna have a
much smaller pool it's gonna be a harder
sell
and
make sure you're hot i'm gonna be honest
like lose
make sure you're hot if you're gonna ask
for these things
because if you're overweight
guys look at that as like you not caring
about your body like how are they
supposed to value your body if you don't
and these aren't fun truths right i'm
not
i i say everything in a happy tone i'm
just a happy person but like it's not a
fun truth to have i'm i would say i'm
probably like 15
pounds overweight to be honest if i do a
bmi that's not a fun truth
but i gotta i gotta figure out how to
lose it send help
and i don't know if the couples that
make videos or talk about waiting until
they were married or whatever waited but
they will never tell you if they felt
like i feel like couples don't tell you
if they felt and it creates this idea
that when you're courting someone to
marriage it's gonna be so easy
everything's gonna be fine i would
really recommend that girls marry
younger if they want to wait till
they're married because
if you want to wait till you're 27 28
you're gonna have a hard time
doing that to be honest like we're
that's when we're the most fertile like
naturally that's when historically we've
had kids
like our bodies want to reproduce
it's not natural to not have sex
throughout your whole 20s
so
if you're dating i would really
recommend
like
dating for marriage within a time frame
from a young age that's what i wish i
did to be honest but i didn't really
know how to like do it like as women
we're given such bad advice like you
know don't chase a man don't let him
know you're interested like he'll find
you like that's bad advice
find the guys that you want and go after
them
i'm not saying like let him court you
don't do like everything make sure he's
actually interested
but it's okay to chase after a guy that
you want and let him know he might
reject you but then you know move on
but yeah there's it's very confusing as
a girl to be honest and you're not going
to be tempted you're not going to feel
like you want to smash i just personally
don't think that they keep it all the
way real i mean i don't think christians
in general keep all the way real and
that's my problem because if you can
just be honest and you can be open you
can actually help people pretending like
you're strong or pretending like you
don't go through things doesn't help
anybody right imagine if i acted like i
was mrs perfect i would not have been
able to help as many people as i've
helped on this youtube channel in such a
short space of time we need to be real
christians be real yourself because god
already sees like god already sees and
you're only fooling yourself but i think
with the couples that are truly waiting
to marriage or the ones that did wait
until marriage all they kind of say is
like set boundaries and it's just so
vague and so unhelpful and it's not the
full story but what i can definitely say
i will say the friends that i have that
actually did wait until they were
married because i do i do know people
that have done that i do know people
that
broke it before and then did it later
and i do know people that waited until
they were married they lived with
christians that helps because
you're going to bring them home to where
with who
they'll they'll look at you and be like
i thought you were
yeah so that's that's what i would
recommend
is that i feel like if i was stronger
when i met my ex i would have been able
to do celibacy in the relationship i
came in there stronger girl you were
you're pretty damn strong if you waited
11 years with the weak and needing him
to carry me and he was weak even though
he wouldn't admit we were both two weak
christians two weak carnal christians
trying to do right by god and it just
didn't work but maybe i will talk about
dating and celibacy not that i've
succeeded in that maybe i shouldn't talk
about it but it'll be interesting to
endeavor and to get into that
conversation maybe i'll have a guest or
something make sure you guys comment
below if you would like that so now i
just want to build a biblical framework
because the bible is so clear about
fornication sexual immorality and sex
before marriage like it's so clear i
don't know how people miss it i cannot
turn the bible especially the new
testament okay i'm gonna end it here
because i think that's like the most
it'd be really interesting to see like
what ages she did all of this just from
like a red pill lens but this is off a
little bit
on
like she definitely didn't do the party
years if she was you know
celibate for all of it but at the same
time at the same time maybe because she
had like the party years in her teenage
years like that ended early i don't know
let me know in the comments don't forget
to subscribe to the channel ring that
notification bell
and i'll talk to you guys next time